[Music]
when I decided to do this work
obviously I'm female and there was an
adolescent once I began to think about
the shape of females lives and I became
very interested in knowing more about
the most excluded girls in the most
excluded in poorest communities
obviously all women face some difference
in their experience regardless of where
they are as to what men experience but
it was very much more dramatic when I
went to the poorer places and saw how
desperately dependent females in you
know sub-saharan Africa Middle East
where I lived and worked for a long time
Central America Asia how much more tied
explicitly their futures were to the
process that was called marriage and
childbearing I was also struck that the
words that were used to describe the
experience gave a very false impression
these were not sentimental marriages
though many of them succeeded mind you
they were made as an economic
calculation of families girls accepted
from an early age that without without
agreeing to their family's wishes they
would not have a place in society there
were cautionary tales of the girls who
didn't marry or who didn't bear children
stories of little girls you know thrown
in the fire young Brides as they're
called thrown in the fire because they
didn't produce a child really dramatic
consequences at the same time wherever
you went you saw the women and girls
working but nobody called it work
they said oh they're helping their
partners when we started looking into
the data we saw that female income was
rededicated to others at a rate of ten
to twenty times that of male income so
if a woman makes a dollar that dollar is
ten times more powerful than a dollar in
a man's hands so the language not only
were the condition
under which they were forced into
marriage represented as something
sentimental and normative but also the
tremendous economic contribution they
made and indeed their dominance in
providing for older and younger
dependents was consistently named
something else
I was once in India with a very
well-known expert in agricultural
development which is very very dominated
and at that time really technologically
focused field and he turned to me he
said oh I see I said women can be
farmers too
the assumption was that farmer meant
male and languages like that all the way
through so when if he women is doing it
oh she's helping her children she's not
earning women themselves girls
themselves will describe what they do in
minimizing and denigrating terms oh I
just help out there's even an issue of
their feeling like they have higher
status if a man is supporting them which
is rare enough so one African country I
was working in I remember they were
having trouble with the census because
women would claim that their husbands
were supporting them because it was seen
as a status that he was supporting them
rather than the reverse females
themselves saw being dependent on male
as a goal because they the society would
not acknowledge the extremely diverse
and heavy burdens that females carry
economically from very young ages I
think one of the really important
differences between male and female
experience is that pretty much
everywhere especially in the developing
world but I think pretty much everywhere
sexual and marital markets and labor
markets for females are completely
connected and aligned to put it kind of
bluntly who you who you have sex with
inside or outside of marriage determines
in many cases your whether you're
socially included in your economic
prospects and not because they're
necessarily being supported by that
person but because they're gatekeepers
to an economy a male who does not marry
or have children is not necessarily
destitute but in most societies if you
ask
the question can this girl aside let's
have a twelve-year-old girl in front of
me if you said well she you're you're
you don't marry and you don't have
children then in effect that's like a
death sentence because there's no social
structure she can fit in
she's stigmatized and she doesn't have
an economic base either so marriage is
above all in most places where the other
sentimental value it may have an
economic arrangement by which women's
time by which girls more often
girls time labor and fertility is is
seated it's Ana monument it's part of
it's basically essential an essential
economic exchange now it's all dressed
up and it's called marriage and it's
interesting right now in the current
time marriage has been made the word
marriage has been made sacred again in
people's minds because they're excluded
groups you know the idea of gay marriage
what people think marriage means in
terms of sharing and caring and
partnership does not apply in many
things called marriages around the world
it is a it is a construct for
controlling young females child marriage
is an example of you know an economic
bargain again I I hate to word just use
the word marriage there because it kind
of sanitizes it the concept but
promising a girl in marriage at a young
age is basically ceding her control over
her spacial movements her body her
bodily functions her privacy physical
integrity female gentle mutilation for
example is persists not because it's
just some idea but because a girl is
seen as non-marriage able if she's not
circumcised or mutilated in the
societies that practice that so in order
for that girl to have a social place and
to have some through witches attached
some economic rights or some economic
access certainly a lot of economic
responsibilities must be married people
used to look at women's status as a
series of individual traits for example
are you
educated are you living away from the
family are you contributing economically
and Susan green halted a wonderful
article years ago looking at the East
Asia Tigers and she pointed out this
these are the countries that were
identified as the first really the
emerging market economies and she
pointed out something very important she
said the the families decide that they
will educate the girl to the level at
which she can join a free trade a trade
free trade zone job and she will be sent
off to work and earn now she lives away
from home she's been educated to some
you know uncommon Lehigh or she received
some education and she's sending money
home but she's not a free person she is
actually being used to support let's say
the higher education of her brother
unless you analyze what the choice is of
the female and then contrast it with the
choice of the male and I always go back
and I say alright in this society in
this setting could a young female decide
that she wanted neither to be sexually
active or to have children or to be
married and still have a social place
and economic possibilities and the
answer is often no in the United States
today it's increasingly yes you can do
that obviously there are still
conditions so it's a kind of process
standard for males you know whether
they're married or not doesn't determine
who they might vote for doesn't
determine pretty much who they live with
doesn't determine how they make their
money the if they're married the their
partner doesn't control whether they can
earn or not the same isn't true with
females often marriage means that the
man is by law even not just by practice
controls her earnings can decide whether
she can have a passport
she needs permission to do almost
anything Drive etc so it's a very very
different experience it's not simply
that men and women are different is that
there are dramatically different
structures of control over females and
their sexuality fertility are tied to
their economic survival
[Music]